when we stepped into doing a challenge
yeah we did a multiple of
10 of our price biggest number and it's
the best way to grow your business and
brand
uh this year and beyond it's a
win-win-win-win-win
it can grow you it could grow the people
you serve it could grow your revenue it
could grow your sales
it can grow your email list like it was
absolutely remarkable and that's why we
continue to do challenges and we
continue to learn
about how to do challenges at a better
and more
world-class level as a youtube creator
it's important to remember
that one of the best ways to build your
income around your youtube channel is to
build a
business around your youtube channel and
today on the think marketing podcast we
are diving deep
into the brand new way for you to market
your business
in 2021 my name is heather torres and
you are listening to the
think marketing podcast the number one
podcast for helping you grow your
influence on youtube
and turn that influence into a high
impact and high profit
online business and today we're going to
be sharing with you this brand new way
that you can start to market your
business now you might be thinking well
heather
i don't quite have a full business don't
worry we're gonna be sharing with you
how you can apply this
to your strategy as you start to grow
and today's episode is brought to you by
startyourmovement.live i'll tell you
more about this
after sean goes through the main content
for today but you want to lean in
because today we are sharing with you
not only this brand new way but eight
lessons that we've learned
from doing this new marketing strategy
three different times throughout the
year
and 10xing our growth here at think
media so
lean in and let's get started with
today's content
[Music]
if you want to launch a new business
from scratch launch a book
grow an existing business or even just
generate
awareness for your brand and create a
deeper connection with your community
i highly recommend you consider doing
a challenge now what exactly is a
challenge
over the past almost a year now think
media has done
three of these i've had many friends in
multiple different industries do these
and they are the hottest new marketing
trend that's really not
new and when i talk about a challenge
to people that are youtube creators this
term could be very
confusing though because actually
challenges are what some people try to
build their youtube niche around
if you've ever heard of the try not to
laugh challenge or boyfriend does
girlfriend's makeup challenge
or the whisper challenge these are not
the challenges that i'm talking about
those are
definitely a type of youtube content but
i'm really talking about
challenges that typically take place
over three five
seven or longer days in some sort of a
private group
usually a private facebook group but it
could even be a discord or a slack or
all kinds of places
and here's exactly what a challenge is
it's a focused
and interactive event designed to help
a specific person overcome a specific
problem maybe you've heard about a 10
days to lose 10 pounds challenge or
something like that it could be
the read a book in a week or read faster
type of a challenge
there's a specific problem a specific
pain point
and a great challenge helps people make
meaningful progress
and get quick and get a quick win and
then invites them
into the next step of your business and
so
the powerful thing about a challenge is
a lot of times they are free they also
could be paid
but you're going to add a ton of value
you're going to help people get a quick
win
help them make progress in a specific
area and then there's probably something
for them to do next
maybe it's purchase your book maybe it's
an online course maybe it's coaching
maybe it's some other aspect of your
business it could even be
physical products challenges are so
popular in the fitness
niche because maybe you do a challenge
to help people
work out and you sell supplements or you
sell workout supplies
and so the two things become
complementary and so
a few facts about challenges and be
thinking about what's a challenge
you could do even if youtube is your
main focus even if
creating weekly youtube content is your
main focus we discovered that actually
doing a challenge
off of youtube was one of the biggest
needle movers in our business and i'm
going to be sharing eight lessons that
we learned from doing these challenges
but the first thing is that they're
usually paid or
free we've only done free challenges
where it's free to be a part of our
seven day
youtube influence challenge but of my
friend stacy tuchel
she does a lot of paid challenges and a
lot of times that's going to be a
smaller group of people but they're
oftentimes more serious and maybe it's
ten dollars maybe it's 20 my friend
pedro did a 31 day
wisdom challenge and it was like 31
because it was like a dollar a day and
there's a bunch of guests and you also
are gonna set a length for a challenge
there's gonna be
three days five days seven days 31 days
31 is kind of insane i'd probably
recommend starting with
three or five we started with seven and
we did two session
sessions a day kind of crazy but a lot
of fun
and here's kind of some examples to get
you thinking about a possible challenge
that you could do my friend pedro he did
a wisdom
challenge and it was actually guest
speakers for 31 days
there's 31 books in the book of proverbs
um it's 31 days in january
he had 31 guest speakers and of course
this is all streamed online
so they were able to just kind of stream
in via zoom
into a private facebook group very
popular are weightless loss challenges
my friend john acuff
has a new book coming out on
overthinking how to overcome
overthinking
so he has a five-day overcoming
overthinking
challenge my friend ben and one of our
students from video ranking academy
from keto camp is doing a seven day
intermittent fasting
challenge and he helps people get their
weight in control and their energy and
control
and kind of learn in a minute
intermittent fasting
and so that's coming up um there could
be all kinds of creative ideas though
there could be a
challenge for building your family tree
or discovering your family history
or maybe to learn a specific piece of
software and i'm going to tell you in a
second the
why challenges are so powerful but
here's the case study for us
and why i think you should consider
doing
a challenge in the next six to 12 months
or even sooner
to really grow your brand impact more
people
what we did was called the youtube
influence challenge and
we've done three of them so far they
were seven days
they were 12 sessions almost two
sessions a day
across seven days and we had free
downloads we had giveaways
and it was quite a bit now one of the
things you may notice about think media
is we're a team of creators you know we
have 13 people on the team
and during the challenge if you're a
part of one let me know in the comments
or
i'll even i you know a review on itunes
or the podcast
like if you were part of one maybe you
saw melissa
and tony and heather and omar or nolan
coming in on the tech days
like we have a whole kind of team to
support
a longer challenge with more sessions
but the powerful thing is even if you're
a solo
preneur working this is a side hustle
you can do a three-day challenge
you can run the tech super easy with
stream yard or with zoom
you could keep it simple and i'd
recommend starting simple
and those are just some thoughts but
here's let's get into the core content
here
eight lessons we learned at think media
from doing
three challenges number one is momentum
our challenge that we did was mainly in
response
to the major disruption that the
pandemic caused
and back in march 2020
uh the pandemic started in february our
profit and loss in our company
was minus twenty thousand dollars right
so we were
like okay what are we going to do are we
making pivots what's going to happen
next
we started looking for answers and that
was also really when i began to talk
with my friend pedro
who actually will tell you about some uh
cool things he has coming up if you're
interested in learning challenges
and he's who taught me and i was like
man like we've
experienced some disruption all my
travels canceled all my speaking's
cancelled
what are we gonna do we decided to do a
challenge and we didn't try to reinvent
the wheel
we worked with somebody who had already
successfully been doing like
50 or more challenges even up until that
point so we we did our first challenge
a couple months later and number one it
was the biggest momentum
builder in our business now here's the
deal a youtube channel that i've been
working on for the past 10 years
of course lots of views lots of
subscribers and yes lots of momentum
in terms of maybe affiliate marketing or
generating some income and growing some
subscribers but here's the thing with
youtube
so i've still noticed people are still
kind of in a passive mode when it comes
to consumption you know what i mean if
you ever watch your audience retention
you probably see the hockey stick effect
like people they check in on the video
they watch a couple minutes they get
distracted they watch something else
and that individual may make some kind
of a connection i'll subscribe and
they're watching something else
when i say momentum not only did it
build momentum in terms of kind of
revenue
but it built momentum in terms of like
just depth by getting people
gathered into a challenge something that
should be challenging
for a few days man momentum just began
again
to build there was like this energy and
like a greater
depth of momentum with our community
than we found possible
with just youtube content or even
podcast content the second thing was
community i mean it was the biggest
community builder
in our business and i think about wide
and depth social media can sometimes
help you reach
wide youtube you get subscribers you go
wow i've got a thousand subscribers i've
got ten thousand i've got a hundred
thousand
it's kind of a wide number there's not a
hundred thousand people
paying attention to you today ready to
like
you know do like even knowing you are
even thinking about you today like if
you've got 100 000 subscribers
one percent maybe five percent of them
are super engaged
what we found was that everybody who
signed up for our challenge
it was the biggest community builder in
terms of depth it accelerated deeper
connections
with our current community and what was
powerful is as we did a seven day
challenge we began to see
people's facebook profiles we saw the
same people daily we saw their names
you see their little face their icon
we're showing up to multiple sessions
and so it was getting unified on the
same page
with our community and keep in mind it's
probably a good point to say that if you
invite your youtube subscribers to be a
part of your challenge not all of them
will want to
but it really gives some a chance to go
to a deeper level
with you number three it's been the
greater greatest accelerator
of know like and trust let's talk about
marketing
when it comes to if you want to sell a
product eventually you create an online
course
you even want to someone's going to make
a buying decision in regards to a camera
they want to invest in or something
a lot of times people take a lot of time
to make those decisions google did a
fascinating article about how long it
takes somebody to buy a minivan
and the typical study of like a mom
researching a minivan for her family
took her three months it took over 300
touch points on google this article
about safety of vans this article about
comparing price this article
about colors this these youtube videos
reviewing different models that she was
into
and so when you think about how long it
takes for someone now a minivan
might cost thirty thousand dollars and a
three dollar
ebook on amazon might not take as long
to build the trust necessary to make a
sale
but the power of challenges is that
there's an acceleration of know like and
trust
that if you want to get somebody really
pumped about your book
your non-profit your business your
products your services
like a challenge it takes people from 0
to 60 real quick that in a three-day
five-day seven-day challenge
there's that focused intensity that fos
focus acceleration of people a
knowing you b having the chance to
determine if they like you or not
three determining if they trust you or
not and we've discovered that sometimes
it takes people in our community
six months or longer to maybe get to
know us
see that we know what we are talking
about when it comes to youtube see that
we really
have the goods that we could really help
people but in a challenge
maybe we meet somebody that we just met
and by the end of seven days or less
they're like okay i can see i know who
you guys are
i understand that you can really help me
i see that you know what you're talking
about
it's the power of a challenge it's the
greatest number one accelerator of
momentum that we've
ever experienced number two community
number three trust number four awareness
it's been the biggest growth of new
people discovering our brand in a
two-week period the first challenge we
did
was i believe in may of 2020 and
after we started to study we started to
study pedro's content
and his materials in terms of how to do
a challenge we started to kind of gather
our ideas
ramp up to it figure out how we were
going to market it and
it was absolutely the biggest
awareness piece of growth when it comes
to our brand and again
think about i don't know how long you've
been connected to like think media but
we have like 1.6 million subscribers but
what i've learned
is that a lot of times just because
someone even subscribes
doesn't know like they really know your
brand you think about this you write
down a mission statement
a vision a vision statement your brand
values your brand colors
even your average super fan they don't
know any of that like ask your average
youtube subscriber like what's the
vision of your company they don't know
the vision of your company
because we're so busy we're maybe
getting a piece of information here and
there
what i found was that number four that
there was the just
awareness of think media of sean cannell
of heather taurus right
and then just kind of actually number
five branding
of actually understanding what we are
about understanding our values
it was the greatest increase in strength
to the think media brand
and that's not surprising because a lot
of people that
went through our challenge spent up to
two hours a day
for seven days really hearing not just
our teaching but hearing our values
hearing our conversations hearing us
answering questions
and with the average view duration or
audience retention on youtube at like
four minutes
and actually right now our average video
viewed per viewer
is like 1.2 videos
meaning out of the thousands or tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people that watch think media
they're watching a video for four
minutes versus
a core group of people a much smaller
group of people that want to really go
deep and be a part of our youtube
influence challenge
they were spending hours with us even if
they were only a part of half the
challenge and one of the things we kind
of learned
was two sessions a day it was maybe a
little bit overkill incredible value
but even people are busy and whatnot and
you know we made a lot of mistakes along
the way as well
but uh branding is so powerful because
they really get to know you at a deeper
level number six
was team this was the most powerful team
building accelerator we've ever
done and again you can absolutely do a
challenge
solo but as a team we were
able to i watched our team confidence
grow our team unity grow
more buy-in to our mission and it gave
us a chance to kind of just
throw more people into the fire if you
will when it came to
the cha in fact to a point i don't even
know if people realized
that think media was as much of a team
we had been through a seas by this time
in may we'd only had a couple months of
omar creating a lot of content nolan
creating a lot of content
no one had really seen tony people knew
heather kind of like some videos
but like people who went through the
challenge was like oh man this is like
the think
squad like this is the think avengers so
it gave us a chance
that's even more of branding it's more
like just awareness to the whole team
as well as just asking people to stretch
themselves level up
i think about at the time melissa caputo
hadn't been in a lot of content or on
camera
very much with our team and now she's
like a super confident speaker super
confident communicator
because of just jumping in and being
challenged
to be a part of a challenge i want to
encourage you one of the reasons you
should do a challenge is not just
because of the people
you're going to impact because it'll
also challenge you
shoot i got to show up i got to get on
camera once i go live i gotta be there
live
and that isn't even if even if it
doesn't go great in terms of your
objectives it will go great in terms of
growing you in this case it grew our
team as leaders
in unity with buy into the mission in
confidence
but it'll do that for you personally i
believe when you commit to doing a
challenge number seven
is value we have a podcast episode
that we'll link up on the show notes uh
that talks about like the money mindsets
i believe
are critical for really building
momentum and revenue in your youtube
business and your business overall
one of those money mindsets is that your
income is correlated
to the amount of value you add to the
marketplace
and i'll admit when we were doing this
challenge
i was scared about how much
free value we were going to give away
and we gave away um
essentially we taught at a 101 level
our proprietary process our seven our
system
and our youtube influ it's called our
youtube influence system that's a part
of our video ranking academy
and my thought was like you know people
always ask what should i put in a course
what should i give away
and the thing is like our course is like
40 hours long
our challenge though was like 10 hours
long it was like a lot it was a 101
level
of of learning all of that content and
again i actually think
that it was a little much not in terms
of like over giving value just like how
much you can consume in a consolidated
uh you know focused piece of time
meaning that i think when we do
challenges in the future
five days we'll do five sessions seven
days we'll do seven sessions instead of
two a day
but all that to say was it was the most
free value we have ever given away but
if your income
is correlated to the amount of value you
give to the marketplace
what we learned number eight was that it
was also the most revenue
generated in our business in a 14-day
period by a multiple of 10.
yeah like we've done some crazy stuff
and i'll tell you about that in a second
but as i finish number seven
value the most free value most training
most knowledge most coaching we've ever
given away
but also the most good will because if
you think about it
people are like man this is this is
amazing and it also gave us a way to
serve people at all different levels
some people
were at a place where especially one of
the reasons why we wanted to do that
and stretch ourselves right when the
world was getting hit hardest by the
pandemic
was to give people tools and resources
and information that they could use
immediately for free so that they could
start earning money building their
influence on youtube and making a
difference working from home maybe
they're unemployed maybe they're
furloughed
but then we also gave people ways to
upgrade so we gave people ways to
get vip or get our starter kit or
eventually join video ranking academy
and a lot of people also said that's
what i want to do as well
so not only it like was multiple layers
of impact
multiple layers of transformation and
multiple layers of not just growing our
business but growing trust
i mean if you i hope you're feeling the
vibe i just want to pass along the
information we learned from doing
challenges
it was absolutely remarkable and number
eight revenue
it was the most revenue generated in our
business in a 14-day period by a
multiple of 10.
in the past we have done what's called
product launch formula where you
pre-record four videos
where we did of course facebook ads and
different promotion
we did like two months of ramping up for
things
we spent tens of thousands of dollars on
facebook ads and different ads
and we did a launch of that and that
simply means that we released the videos
and we've sent emails we did all the
things
and we generated around 170 000
that was our biggest previous launch
and when we stepped into doing a
challenge yeah
we did a multiple of 10 of our price
biggest number
so this is why you know we're talking
about in this video why this is the
you know the hot new marketing trend
that will grow your income and influence
faster than
anything else and it's the best way to
grow your business and brand
uh this year and beyond is because
it's a win-win-win-win-win it can grow
you
it could grow the people you serve it
could grow your revenue it could grow
your sales
it can grow your email list like it was
absolutely remarkable and that's why we
continue to do challenges and we
continue to learn
about how to do challenges at a better
and more world-class level so i want to
encourage you what's one challenge you
could do
what's a three-day challenge you could
do to get your email list started
what's like a a challenge you could do
what it what problem do you solve
how do you help people who do you help
who's the people you help how could you
put a challenge together to help them
solve
one pain point and even better than that
if you already have
a product you already have an online
course listen as we launch books in the
future we're going to launch them with
challenges
that's why my friend john acuff is doing
the overthinking challenge for his
overthinking book
in the past i've been a part of book
launches i've launched youtube secrets
it did very well
we put so much different energy into so
many different aspects of marketing
we're doing like we're trying to run
around do podcasts great we're trying to
do all this email marketing create all
these videos and do all these live
streams awesome
we're hustling and trying to do all
these with this advice from different
book marketers about
paying for kindle ad things so it's on
amazon and all this other stuff which is
all great but it became very complex
there's like a list of 100 things to do
what i've learned is that if you just do
like a challenge
and you want to again launch a book an
online course
your services your coaching connect with
a group of people
that you can help and serve and some of
those people might want to hire
to do consulting with you once you've
proved you can help them
and some might say i want to hire you
later like i'll work with you like
now i know you i'm not at the exact
moment where i'm ready to make a buying
decision which is something you never
want to forget because
not everyone's always ready to make a
buying decision today
they're going to buy the minivan three
months from now
so you want to continue to be able to
add content add value get them to know
you get them to fall in love with your
minivan
so that when the time comes to buy the
minivan they know that you're the go-to
person the go-to authority the person
that they want to work with
in terms of how you help and serve
people so i want to encourage you a
well-designed
and well-executed challenge i believe is
the most important marketing campaign to
be running right now
does this replace youtube of course not
that's front-end content and awareness
that is your front-end brand i think
doing a video podcast even like
the think media podcast is something
super powerful
that you can do in terms of generating
awareness and generating impact
but ultimately consider doing a
challenge and i want to encourage you if
you want more help heather's going to
tell you
more about how you could be a part of
our mentor
in challenges pedro adeos content that
will help you crush it with challenges
and so uh go all in man this is this is
a big deal and i'm excited about it
well i don't know about you but i am
fired up and excited for the next
challenge here at think media and
if you want to go deeper into learning
how you can do your own challenge
we want to bring the expert to you and
that is our friend
pedro adeo he is the challenge king
and he's worked with not only us here at
think media but people like
dean graziosi russell brunson damon john
ryan dice and so many other high-profile
entrepreneurs who are crushing it with
challenges right now so
if you want to figure out how to get
your message out there if you want to
figure out
how you can utilize this brand new way
of marketing
so that you can not only just grow your
influence but grow the impact that you
have on this
world then you definitely want to sign
up for pedro's next challenge
at startyourmovement.live that's going
to get you to where you need to go
if you're interested in going through a
challenge to see how it is
but not only that for you to get
inspired for you to
go deeper in understanding what is the
strategy and the tactics that i need to
actually apply
when creating not just a challenge but a
successful challenge because that's what
we want
for you here at think we want you to be
successful
we want you to not only grow your
youtube channel but also
grow your business so you can leave a
legacy in this world so
go to startyourmovement.live right now
after you're done listening to this
podcast to get started on the five day
challenge
now if you're getting value out of this
podcast i want to encourage you to like
if you're listening
on youtube but also to rate and review
this podcast over on
itunes this means the world to us when
we get to see
you in the comments in the rating and
reviews over
not in the rating and reviews in the
reviews of the podcast
because we get to hear from you and see
what you love about what we are
producing here at think so
today's podcast listener is
melissa melissa says sean heather and
think media your podcast is one of the
best things in my life
especially on tuesday mornings i look
forward to them
your expert content backed by honest
promises built so much trust and values
i appreciate you
thank you for the abundance of knowledge
that you share i
love it explanation mark i'm a true
follower and subscriber and now
a lifer thank you so much your podcast
makes all the difference in how i see
youtube and make
and makes the play and edit button on
the camera
that much more friendlier for your
guidance melissa well melissa thank you
so much for
being a lifer here at think that means
so much to me because i know that you're
in this
you're in this not only to grow a
youtube channel but to make an
impact in the world and so i just want
to say thank you so much for leaving
that and
if you've not shared this podcast with a
friend
what are you waiting for i'm sure you
know someone who needs this content so
share it with someone in your life who
is an entrepreneur or someone that you
know
should be starting a challenge this year
and we want to thank you so much for
being a part of our think community
we love you so much and we cannot wait
for you to
grow your youtube channel this year
we'll see you in the next episode
[Music]
you